il y est
[Musique]
c'est dans un cadre somptueux à la
chapelle royale du château de versailles
que le département des yvelines a décidé
d'organiser un concert caritatif pour
l'ukraine j'ai une tradition de
générosité dans le département des
yvelines
le drame des populations ukrainienne à
proximité c'est presque à nos frontières
nous incite naturellement très fortement
à comme on dit faire quelque chose et se
conserve ce soir est une des nombreuses
actions que à l'initiative du
département
les fonds récoltés ont été entièrement
reversés à la fondation de france soit
une somme de 42 mille 900 euros chacun
peut agir faire un concert réunir des
artistes faire s'élever la musique tout
en offrant des dons pour soutenir les
populations qui souffrent c'est la chose
la plus utile la plus généreuse et la
plus solidaire que l'on puisse faire
chacun peut faire un geste à sa mesure
l'ambassadeur de l'ukraine en france
vadim omeltchenko étaient également
présents au concert lors de sa prise de
parole il a demandé au public de
respecter une minute de silence pour les
ukrainiens victimes de la guerre
l'émotion était très présente ce sont
trois jeunes réfugiés ukrainiens qui ont
ouvert le concert résidant en france
depuis le début de la guerre renata
notamment joué un morceau au piano
qu'elle a spécialement créé pour
l'ukraine
je ressens beaucoup de chagrin beaucoup
de douleur peut-être un peu de peur
aussi mais je suis très honoré car c'est
un lieu chargé d'histoire les sentiments
sont très mélangées et partagé d'un côté
une joie ce soir de faire quelque chose
pour l'ukraine aider mais d'autre part
aussi une tristesse parce que notre pays
est en guerre
je suis très ému
la musique de bach que je vais jouer ce
soir je vais travailler avec un ami qui
se trouve aujourd'hui dans une ville
occupée par des russes il ne sait pas ce
qui l'attend donc l'émotion est très
grande
un chanteur franco ukrainien de l'opéra
national de paris a également fait
spécialement le déplacement
ça me touche au plus profond de moi
parce que ma famille est toujours en
ukraine
mes amis
se trouvent dans les régions a fortement
touché par la guerre dans les zones de
combat
donc si je peux faire quelque chose dit
si
c'est pour eu pour d'autres l'ukrainien
qui est
qui souffrent aujourd'hui le concert
s'est clôturée par l'interprétation de
l'hymne ukrainien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]